qu'est ce que vous allez vous je vous
sauver
j'ai une fille de 18 ans et ce matin
elle a eu un accident très prêt à porter
charge aux urgences vraiment désolé
quand j'étais adolescente j'ai failli me
noyer alors vous avez quitté votre corps
ça m'est arrivé plusieurs fronts c'est
pour ça que j'ai demandé à ce cas de
m'étrangler il faut que j'ai
l'impression de me noyer
maman oui tu es encore à l'art
ça fait tellement
j'ai cru d'abord perdu tuer tous cas
j'ai
ma petite fille elle avait cinq en cinq
ans que la fumée qui n'a tué par les
flammes on devrait lui demander de
rester
en charbon vous vous êtes melli de
quelque chose qui vous regardait pas
maintenant vous ne reconnaissez pas
votre vie chaque esprit fini par quitter
son corps un jour ou l'autre tu m'as
manqué les jo comment tu connais mon
enfant mais
dis moi dis juste essayé
de défendre
tu avait suscité les femmes etc ben
helli on parle de ma fille bill est
morte ça s'est marié il faut que tu
m'aides à la perdre pour arrêter ça
tu peux pas lui faire de peine si tu
savais tout ce que je peux faire
personne ne va battre ce pauvre con sauf
moi
[Rires]
[Musique]
ballon et n 2 sous
non pas l'école
amy locane
non
baby
[Musique]
nous avons découvert quelque chose
d'incroyable maroc et mon équipe a été
autorisée à commencer il faut
c'est non ce que tu vas vivre et le
maroc c'est magnifique tu vas adorer
bâtiment mais l'école aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui et tous les autres joueurs
on va sortir de la rue si jamais tu as
besoin je planterai tout
et je reviendrai prix
capitale
désolé mais je nous reste nouvelle
capitale pack solide c'est un honneur de
vous rencontrer nous sommes d'accord sur
le fait que j'ai pas hors de question de
négocier une mission de sauvetage une
fois localisés on pourra les extraire
american sera exécuté samedi soir après
la prière si la rançon n'est pas payé
il doit bien que j'aime ma femme plus
que tout au monde photo ce qui sera
nécessaire
ouvert du reste bien à l'affût et ramé
keita de maysan que la fête commence
younès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il vaut mieux
roy hill président
les ambassadeurs ou sache pas certaine
chose
[Musique]
l'année ap ap la
alet les bains en train de s'enfuir ces
jeux de calais un test ma voiture adam
lescar christine
ne courais pas après l'argent devenez un
spécialiste et faites moi confiance
l'argent suivre
john m'a dit vous voyez me parler je
devais venir parce que je voudrais que
tu remplaces franck mais qui m'a nommé
directeur à sa place
ouais
[Musique]
c'est l'heure du grand sens
ce petit bruit sec que vous avez entendu
j'ai plongé dans moins d'un mètre de
profondeur
restiez d'alain tu te trouves à
l'hôpital au moment de l'impact votre
tête est brusquement parti en avant ce
qui a brisé vos 6e à dix septième
vertèbre vous allez être atteint d'une
forme de paralysie sur le long terme que
vous ne pourrez peut-être pas recouvrer
plus de capacités que celle que vous
avez aujourd'hui mais chaque fois que sa
mère rue
[Musique]
salue le voilà
marché enfin moment
c'est parfois vie horrible tous les
matins réveil ont fait choix le vo
lester dans la mienne il faut essayer
suppositoire moines en barrage et poker
ce soir donc je te dis à demain je sois
très doux et tous ces trucs là je
m'appelle adam bébé américain fait
[Musique]
tu te rends pas compte de l'impact que
tu peux avoir sur tes collègues au
bureau si un jour je revenais bosser
boom les performances seraient tout
simplement existantes c'est pas comme si
tu étais patineur artistique du vendée
des crédits par téléphone est bidouillée
un truc pour toi abus sur ta main pour
avertir au rasoir maintenant si papa je
t'en prie super je suis pas très bon et
que tu c'est avec ce genre de sauce us
et à quoi dire d'autre part tout cas
c'est ici
à partir de là
[Musique]
et aucune idée des épreuves que tu peux
traverser dans ta vie tous les jours
depuis le début ses patientes avec moi
j'étais en colère soir là elle m'a
toujours traité comme une personne de ce
que j'ai fait
mais c'est quoi un proche
tu es un vrai petit voyage du voix des
peuples toujours apte à tirer des angles
tu vas faire quoi maintenant d'un nouvel
endroit nouvelle vie non
tu fais quoi plus tard j'irai dormir
d'accord c'est comme ça que tu as vite
une fille a dit que j'étais en train de
vie tel ennemi qu à charge et tout ça
mais qui me qu'ils évitent bien
quelqu'un qui se balade avec plus d'un
million de notre marchandise je veux que
vous retrouviez mon stock
la ferme combien de fois on va devoir
venir te voir on peut pas faire affaire
comme ça on a besoin de temps tu dois
maintenant vous allez retourner chercher
l'argent écoute il fallait que quelqu'un
s'oppose enfin à ces types quelqu'un
devait le faire et tu l'as fait
j'ai un message pour toi tu es un amor à
ré
écouter des italiens il connaît les
russes il connaît tout le monde n'est
pas prêt de revoir ahmed par ici
tu plaisantes et
russ prêts les prêts l'ipres pour ça que
je t'aime et mickey et c'est quoi ton
port m'occuper des ruses pour toi
quelqu'un nous prend pour cibles
à qui leur a permis de caler tout ce
qu'ils possèdent maintenant tu sais ce
qu'ils te reste à faire
ono est devenu un contrat c'est un chien
de combat il faut qu'on fasse quelque
chose et si on est les prochains
[Musique]
la meilleure amie elle est morte où tu
es là
écoutez moi j'ai faites quoi vous avez
peur mais je suis plus cette fille
dépressive dix mois en du rêve je suis
vraiment désolé
vous étiez inscrit dans son répertoire
comme la personne à appeler en cas
d'urgence ou et ma soeur fait simplement
l'avoir violemment par des conseils
restent attractifs
[Musique]
est ce que le docteur clarke mais chez
les sioux janus on s'apprêtait on
s'apprêtait à dîner vous voulez vous
joindre à nous je sais ce que vous êtes
en train de prouver je suis désolé une
famille c'était social mais vous en avez
une superbe
je ne suis pas votre ennemi donc leur
clark je n'ai jamais dit faut les tuer
c'est quoi ton problème avec celui
contre
je pense que cette j'aime ce qui est
derrière ça
buzz non
[Musique]
pourquoi tu me regardent comme ça tu
fais comme si tu me croyais pas
salut docteur
james blake est un individu très
dangereuse a dit d'arrêter la voiture
parce qu'il est uniquement fou il l'a
tuée je reste à l'intérieur et qui
portait la double auto
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce sera encore sauter
oui c'est
ouais merci ma puce je t'appelle dès que
j'arrive là-bas
joli corps libre à mon pote c'est ta
copine non c'est erin walton la fille du
juge walton
tu as dit on chauffeur est nouveau ouais
pourquoi devrait-on pairs pour être sûr
[Musique]
tous sont pas légion qu'est-ce qu'on
fait papa ours et de bébés ours on les
supprime jaune a dit que vous êtes un
béret vert appelle son père à bas les
rides
pas d'espoir tout de suite sa corde vous
avez à faire une équipe de terrain
hautement qualifiés je tiens ta fille
sais tu ne fais pas ce que je te demande
de faire quelque chose d'horrible va lui
arriver
il aurait dû prendre ton colis est
parent est vite fait
hommage à
21 ans il est responsable de la mort de
cinq ans d'un stop il est dangereux et
n'hésitera pas à vous tuer t'étais au
courant de tout ça alors tu viens juste
de tuer ce cas il allait tuer
c'est pas vrai ça me dit par dire en
avant d'une personne fabrique
[Musique]
je te laisser la place
salut alors le boulot ça a été qu'est-ce
que tu l'aies
dans quelle facture va envoyer ton
dossier j'ai pas on est en train d'en
parler avec josh donc tu as gardé ce
plan suivent josh dans la femme qu'il
choisira toi et maman vous êtes des
amours de jeunesse holy dis surtout pas
que vous étiez faits l'un pour l'autre
fargo il va me faire bien qu'on étaient
faits l'un pour l'autre ouais c'est ce
que je veux on était
tout est compliqué mais
fini a toujours une solution
[Musique]
j'ai déjà vu cette voiture la banque ces
gens sont pas forcément
accroche toi
on n'a pas une minute à perdre il faut
qu'on parte ils ont trouvé
on va aller dans un endroit sûr adieu
les états unis adieu les pompiers
qu'est ce qu'il a fait je suis désolé
prépare ton sac on part dans dix minutes
à quel point dans la merde en réalité
plus avant certaines choses seraient
parfois
bien sûr que si on peut tout réparer
mais pour ça il faut le voir aucun homme
apprécié cette situation
malheureusement si tu ne prends pas la
bonne décision c'est ce qui va arriver
[Musique]
ce qu'on s'apprête à faire ça pourrait
passer pour un très mauvais exemple ça
va être une super aventure
[Musique]
une bande de fugitifs se dirige vers le
mexique
j'avais prévu derek et avoir une vie je
peux pas rester en cavale avec vous
trois jusqu'à la fin des jours
qu'est ce qu'il a fait est un succès
c'est difficile à expliquer
[Musique]
pour m'intéressait beaucoup si vous êtes
c'est lui que tout est parce que vous
êtes
permettez moi de vous dire que nous
n'apprécions pas beaucoup cette
conversation
pourquoi vous lui faites ça
pourquoi lui il vous fait ça
vous coûte à lyon
[Musique]